[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock is the party over for boris
johnson fresh calls for his resignation
this morning after a revelation about an
indoor gathering to mark his own
birthday during the first lockdown with
singing
the cake will speak to the transport
secretary grant shaps and also the
former deputy prime minister michael
hesseltein plus as tensions bubble in
ukraine and after a chess move from the
west we'll talk to the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy plus one of the
former chiefs of staff of the armed
forces general sir richard barrons it is
tuesday the 25th of january
let them eat cake the prime minister
facing fresh calls to quit after dining
street admits he attended a gathering in
the cabinet room to mark his birthday
during lots the prime minister is a
national distraction he's got to go
the prime minister under more pressure
over what went on behind this door in
the summer of 2020 now a birthday
celebration he admits attending
on alert with more russian tanks on the
move the u.s puts thousands of troops on
watch for possible deployment to eastern
europe as tensions in the ukraine ramp
up
this is really important i had a very
very very good meeting total unanimity
with all the european leaders
cameroon crushed at least six people are
reported to have died in a stampede at a
stadium hosting the africa cup of
nations
dover delays as lorry drivers face long
queues we ask is brexit finally
beginning to bite we'll speak to the
boss of the port
also on the programme for you this
morning
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody puts baby in a corner we'll speak
to the stars of dirty dancing as the
movie is transformed into a west end
show
the big freeze i'm going to be speaking
to preet chandi who has become the first
asian woman to complete a solo
unsupported expedition to the south pole
[Music]
good morning everybody a cake
and a chorus of happy birthday the
claims about festivities during a
gathering in downing street and the
downing street admits the prime minister
was at to mark his own birthday inside
number 10 during the first lockdown
covered restrictions at the time said
indoor social gatherings were banned in
a public or private place calls now for
the labour leader and others for the
prime minister to resign here's john
craig
boris johnson's 56th birthday on the
19th of june 2020 with greetings from
children at a primary school in
hertfordshire and a cake baked by staff
at the school
but later that day it's reported the
prime minister had a surprise birthday
party with more cake and party food in
the cabinet room in downing street
despite lockdown rules at the time
forbidding social gatherings indoors the
prime minister is a national distraction
he's got to go
one cabinet minister admits some of the
recent partying allegations are more
serious than the latest claims there
have been some quite serious allegations
made those have been investigated i
don't think
that these latest uh allegations that
have been made
fit into that category i think they've
gone slightly over the top on the
gathering in the afternoon of the pm's
birthday number 10 says
a group of staff working in number 10
that day gathered briefly in the cabinet
room after a meeting to wish the prime
minister a happy birthday he was there
for less than 10 minutes
but on claims about the pm's family
upstairs in his flat in the evening
number 10 insists this is totally untrue
in line with the rules at the time the
prime minister hosted a small number of
family members outside that evening
but three months before his birthday in
2020 mr johnson wrote to a
seven-year-old girl josephine from
hampshire
telling her she'd set a great example by
postponing her birthday party and
including a hashtag
be like josephine
now a prime minister who famously said
the uk could have its cake and eat it
and brexit appears to be praying for
respite from the party allegations
john craig sky news
transport secretary's here grant chaps
it's sensational to have you in the
studio okay lovely to be here hello i'm
coming to an end
you didn't bring a red box with you um
talk to me first of all about the great
news about transport and travel yeah so
really pleased to say it's been a long
time in coming when you go abroad there
are no more tests to take when you come
home so you don't need to take a test
before you leave wherever you're coming
from to get here you don't need to take
a day two the day eights are already
gone you can just come home and the only
thing we ask you to do is fill in a
passenger locator form which we are
going to simplify by the way that would
be good yes and it's ridiculously
complicated to work your way through so
you'll fill in one of those uh passenger
location forms that's it no quarantine
no testing and all that cost will drop
away
sensational from the 11th of february i
think 11th of february in time for the
half term break and a couple of other
small things including um children 12 to
15 being able to use the nhs copied app
to demonstrate uh that they've been
vaccinated that's where countries
require that and uh all under 18's uh
exempt anyway so it's going to be a on
the way back so it's going to be a big
change much cheaper and i'm really
delighted nobody wants to be going to
ukraine at the moment though do the u.s
troops um are on high alert what should
the uk be doing well the prime minister
met with biden several european leaders
last night we've made it very very clear
to president putin that there will be
severe consequences uh if he crosses
that border
well uh i i don't want to go into too
much detail but economic and economic
response would be very strong but
britain's also sent
defense
weapons and training to the ukraine's
ukrainians in order to assist with uh
protecting the country could there be a
military response well that is already
partially a a military response and look
i think the important thing is that
president putin should be under no doubt
at all that the international coalition
is there and very tightly coordinating
which is why that meeting yesterday was
so important uh to
to make sure that this will not be
would not be cost free and he should not
do it can you envisage a scenario where
there are british troops on the ground
in ukraine
uh well there are already um british
troops in support or or uh military
support to the ukrainians with some
defensive uh weapons so that is already
the case i don't want to go into too
much detail but i think what i mean but
but what i will but what i will say is
ukraine is a independent sovereign
nation uh that sovereignty should be
expect respected in total in total
including crimea it would be completely
unacceptable for him to cross the uh
border and there will be a very strong
and very coordinated response if he does
okay
you're a father aren't you um i want to
show you this letter from um josephine
seven-year-old josephine wrote to the
prime minister
and she was praised by the prime
minister um because she had said that
she wasn't going to have a party because
she wanted to abide by the rules um
thoughts on that given what happened
yeah no i've seen that letters
and it's lovely and as you say i'm a dad
and i wasn't able to see my dad who was
in hospital for four months so i
understand the sense of concern uh about
the sort of reports we see on the on the
front of the
newspapers it obviously was the prime
minister's birthday he'd been given a
cake earlier in the day that's the
picture in the newspapers and he was
clearly given a cake by his staff when
he got back to the office these are
staff he would have been working with
and was working with all day long
and will have been many of times in the
same room with them
working on the response to coronavirus
they come in give them a cake i
understand anything lasted for 10
minutes
and that was it
uh 11th of june let's just let's just
unpack it then should we 11th of june um
which was eight days before the event in
the cabinet room this is what he said in
downing street
we relax the rules on meeting outdoors
so that groups of up to six could gather
provided they are socially distant
but you couldn't gather inside yes
i should just point out that uh that
picture is obviously from earlier in the
day when he when he was that's all right
then the the school um outside i should
point out the uh
work responses people working in uh
essential areas and obviously including
the response to coronavirus in in in
downing street were already working
together so there wasn't a gathering of
people who weren't already
working in the same building he would
have been in the cabinet room as it
turns out in this case many many many
times with those people working uh on
the response socially distance uh uh you
know it was my birthday and they brought
it in
okay well family
because the unusual thing about downing
street is both a home and a and an
office and family members can always
could always throughout this environment
his interior designer was there
again she says that she wasn't invited
to
any any parties so
she was there she was in the building of
course and she said she was told that
she was going to have a meeting with the
prime minister in the middle of the day
when he was navigating a global pandemic
you've got to be kidding me well look
well i wasn't there but all i can do is
wrong transport secretary and still you
can keep a straight face well look at
okay as you know uh mistakes were made
and the prime minister said that you
know yourself mistakes were made during
coronavirus sometimes people would
regret the things that they uh did um
this was a period of slightly more
relaxed uh
rules well the prime minister's already
said that he apologizes for any mistakes
that were made i do understand as soon
as i understand that sue gray was
already aware of this uh particular uh
incident and so she will be using that
in her report and we'll wait to see what
she says rishi soonett was there
well look again everyone who works in uh
the building will have been in meetings
constantly with the prime minister
including rishi sunak including the
prime minister and his his staff
just be clear the prime minister clearly
didn't organize to be given a cake some
people came forward and thought it would
be appropriate for on his birthday
at the time let's just look at the rules
at the time then shall we this is what
the rules were saying at the time can we
look at those
here we go
no person may participate in a gathering
which takes place in a public or private
place outdoors and consists of more than
six people indoors and consists of more
than two persons yes
people working together were in in
essential areas were obviously working
together so you you can't you you know
an office building yes that's right but
an office building uh already required
people to work together so the cabinet
room was an office building
well it isn't yes so i was the interior
designer in it well she was working
in the building and this was at a period
uh when the she come next door down
three flights of stairs well look she
already said that she wasn't in invited
the event but look you're bigger your
bigger point but she had a meeting i
don't know she had a meeting but why
would the wider let's unpack that why
would an interior designer
that was doing a flat come down three
flights of stairs go next door and go in
to see a prime minister who was trying
to navigate a global pandemic you're
asking me questions i can't provide the
answer to because i wasn't there
i mean it looks as though it's against
the rules to me unfortunately i was
gonna say fortunately um sue gray who's
already aware of this will be able to
get to the bottom of that which i think
is actually the right way to do it but
kay look i understand the sense of
frustration i say to you i could not see
my own dad who we didn't think we were
going to see again when he went into
hospital he then remained there for four
months i feel personally very upset when
i see
stories about
you know lockdowns being broken in in
any form and many people have found that
they crossed the wrong side of that line
at different times
i understand that it upsets uh it upsets
me but the prime minister's already
already said that he takes full
responsibility for everything that
happens in in downing street and the
same in this case this is what he said i
was going to say just he said let me
just tell you this this is what he said
on the 8th of december to the house of
commons
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken
well as i say he he didn't organize a
party uh someone presents a cake to him
and singing
happy birthday mr prime minister happy
birthday to you
it was his birthday and these are people
that he work with all the time as i said
i don't seek to
defend it this is for sue gray to decide
on uh whether this was appropriate
she'll make the recommendations i think
we can be pretty clear the prime
minister didn't present a cake to
himself this is somebody coming in
with that cake and i've explained to you
that i'm furious with everybody but
you're not defending it are you but okay
i'd say i'm furious with everybody who
broke the rules and a lot of different
people will have found that you know
perhaps unwittingly the trangress
transgressed the the the rules during
the period of lockdowns that is a fact
uh it's quite right that um that that's
investigated the prime minister
apologizes if uh and where uh he has uh
transgressed uh and uh you know uh these
are people who with whom he would have
been in the room many many times
probably that day as well
uh for a series of meetings
with the coronavirus response the fact
that it's his birthday and they then say
oh and here's a cake i don't think
changed the fact that he was in the room
with them in any case but other matters
how often do people gather in the
cabinet room when they're not cabinet
secretaries oh that room is used as a
meeting room all the time particularly
what's during corona virus i think
there's not cakery i was going to say
because there's a
back door that can be open so you get a
flow of air it's a larger room so you
could meet socially distance so it would
have been used constantly throughout
corona virus including a few days before
when the prime minister came in with
rishi sunak and and paid his respects to
the loss of life on the front line with
the frontline workers there he is very
somber indeed and as you can see days
later he was it doesn't matter he was
breaking the rules everybody in that
room about 30 people
were breaking the rules and that's
breaking so
let me just put the question to you if i
may breaking the rules and thus breaking
the law should they all be issued with a
fixed penalty notice so first of all the
should they so let me just answer your
question first of all the circumstances
are disputed so i understand that number
10 are saying that there was nowhere
near 30 people i'm not there sue gray
will be able to answer that and that's
what she'll do and secondly there will
have been many occasions when exactly
the same staff were meeting in that room
because you could be socially distanced
the door uh opens uh and these are
people that the prime minister will have
been working with all of the time so the
difference here is that a cake was
entered into brought into the
singing which was also against the rules
of the time yeah and again sue gray will
have to report back on that and look as
i say uh and the interior designer was
that uh as i say she'll have to report
back on all the facts i know that the
interior designer she wasn't uh invited
and sue gray will have to answer the
questions i wasn't i wasn't there okay i
wasn't invited so you're asking me to
respond no all i'm asking no i'm not i'm
saying it's i'm giving you the facts
that we know that uh there were more
people there than were allowed to be
there at the time thus breaking the
rules thus breaking the law so should
they all get a fixed penalty
so so i think i'm right in saying that
in uh the working uh environment when
people were uh in downing street they
would have been together these the same
group of people would have been together
many many times they would have been
from his uh from his office they would
have been working together they probably
met in there earlier that day or other
days i imagine to
discuss the coronavirus response the big
differences here that someone presented
a a cake as you say um look i i we can
go around in circles but the only thing
that i think
i acknowledge that it's upsetting for me
personally not being able to see my
father whenever i hear a transgressions
from the rules okay
okay i can see where you're going with
that however as far as fixed penalty
notices are concerned uh people got
fixed penalty notices for breaking the
rules do you think they should i think
first of all we should get to the facts
and that's what sue grey would will do i
understand she was already aware of this
so this is not new to her or her report
so she will have been already discussing
the circumstances in the kind of detail
that you've you've quizzed me on i'm
afraid i don't know have the answers to
but you did say you were furious with
anybody that broke the rules are you
would you be furious with the prime
minister if it proves it's proven that
he broke well look
the prime minister was clearly presented
with the cake he's already said with
regard to that outside uh gathering on
the 20th i think it was uh that uh
talking about he should have gone out
there and said
away indoors singing cake 30 people
maybe a few no i think maybe some fewer
than that
his interior designer was there look
again we've got to love it we are we are
you're doing a very very good job of
you're doing a very very good job of
going round around in circles and the
only indeed a humanist helpfully tell
you because you're asking me things
beyond my
sphere of knowledge and that's why sue
gray is looking into it and she will be
able to give us the full background what
i don't really think is uh is right you
get the sort of drip drip of of uh
reports in the media let's get the facts
and i don't think we'll have to wait
very long and then we'll all be able to
see what the facts were and as always
happens with these things it will turn
out that perhaps some of the stories
were uh written in a way which were you
know
was designed to look in a certain way
this the the prime minister who you know
months earlier had been
very close to to death from um from
covid was lucky to come out of hospital
is working incredibly hard being out on
a visit and presented with a cake early
in the day comes back to his office
where he's working with the same bunch
of people he's working with all the time
and they decided to give him a cake for
his birthday now sue gray will tell us
the the rights and wrongs of that and
i'm happy to wait for her to i'm
guessing come 11th of february won't
have any restrictions if he wants to go
on holiday
well everyone will be able to get away
at last that's true and and do so
without all the cost when they come home
thank you very much taking the time much
appreciated let's have a look at how the
newspapers are looking at that this
morning the guardian leading this
morning on downing street parties
following the allegations of birthday
parties with boris johnson in number 10.
the times also leads with the latest
party claims and has the same picture of
the prime minister with a cake
given to him
on his birthday the mirror says 30
guests broke the ban on indoor
gatherings and the sun
a familiar phrase you can't have your
birthday cake and eat it boris
still to come on the programme before
you we will get the view from labour as
we're joined by the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy
laurie drivers facing long waits and
queues at dover will speak to the boss
of the port
at quarter to eight speaking to the
chief exec of heathrow airport with
coveted 19 rules set to be eased for
travelers arriving in england
but before all of that thousands of us
troops have been put on standby and
ships and fighter jets are being moved
to eastern europe as tensions grow
between east and west over ukraine as
mark stone reports
at a white house meeting to discuss
soaring inflation in america there was a
more pressing question could you give us
a brief update on your call with
european leaders on what's happening in
ukraine today
the only reason i don't like doing this
is you never report on why i've called a
meeting
and this is really important i had a
very very very good meeting total
unanimity with all the european leaders
we'll talk about it later thank you
if he was terse it's because this crisis
is growing by the day he had just
concluded a hastily arranged meeting
with key european allies again they
agreed the shared hope for a diplomatic
solution but this was a meeting to agree
sanctions and military options too not
into ukraine at the moment but to
bolster defenses in eastern europe we
are considering to further enhance our
presence in the eastern part of the
alliance
this could include the deployment of
additional nato battle groups
the meeting here and the talk of troop
deployment is an acceptance that
vladimir putin is showing no sign of
changing course but it bluntly shows too
that nato leaders feel there is now an
urgent need to show some sense of unity
and heightened preparation when the
reality is that so far there has been
little of either at the weekend at camp
david the president's military advisers
presented a plan for troops to be on
standby as part of a nato rapid reaction
force the details now confirmed at the
pentagon all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert
comes up to about 8 500 personnel
all this is according to president
putin's spokesman western hysteria
we want to draw your attention to the
fact that the escalation of tensions is
being held by activity and actions
undertaken by the us and nato as he cast
nato as the aggressor more russian
forces arrived in belarus just north of
the ukrainian capital kiev a hundred
thousand battle-ready russians are now
to the east to the north and to the
south of ukraine uh while we can't get
into the mine of president putin we are
seeing the preparations that they're
making at the border
this is now the biggest test for europe
for america for the west in many decades
and that is precisely what vladimir
putin wanted mark stone sky news in
washington
our defense and security editor debra
haynes is standing by for us um hello to
you deborah interesting to hear from the
transport secretary saying all options
open as far as the uk is concerned
yes and everyone is basically still
hoping that uh
despite despite all the signs to the
country that diplomatic efforts will
establish some kind of solution but
clearly preparing for the worst and in
terms of the um the sort of signaling
from nato that they are ready to bolster
their uh their their enforce their um
their defenses along their eastern flank
it's all designed to try to send a
signal to vladimir putin to draw back to
pull back not to go forward not to
continue with this threat that the west
have that he's planning a further
invasion of ukraine he's always denied
any intention of that and has said that
this latest steps by nato uh western
hysteria but we really are right now at
a crucial moment where it can't continue
at this level of heightened tension
something is going to have to move one
way or the other and what you're seeing
is uh western allies preparing for the
worst but still hoping that that won't
come
okay deborah fernandez thank you very
much indeed thanks a lot
um and coming up in just a few moments
time we're also going to be speaking to
the former deputy prime minister um we
will be asking him lord hesseltown of
course asking him about what's happening
in ukraine as well as what's been
happening in downing street over the
last 18 months or so and also we'll be
speaking to uh general sir richard
barrens the former commander of joint
forces about ukraine that's uh in about
five minutes time
meantime the metropolitan police have
apologized to a language lecturer who
was strip searched in 2013 constantina
duff described being pinned to the floor
by three officers the police have
apologized for the language used by the
officers about mustaf's appearance
london mercedes khan said what happened
was utterly disgraceful
a woman in texas has been charged after
trying to purchase a child for half a
million us dollars at a walmart police
were contacted after rebecca lynette
taylor approached a mother and son in a
queue and asked how much she could
purchase him for before following them
to the car park
studies find that every 30 deaths caused
by covet at least one other person died
from another condition who could have
been saved under normal circumstances
researchers at warwick university have
found that an increase in preventable
non-covered deaths is driven by patients
who needed urgent care but who did not
receive it
we see one of the main drivers and
important factors behind this is staff
absence rates we see that you know as
hospitals get hit with more covet
admissions invariably the risk of
hospital staff falling sick and being
absent increases and that in turn uh
sort of drives the excess mortality
among non-coveted patients
let's have a look at the latest covert
figures for you should we another 88 and
a half thousand new cases in the uk in
the latest 24-hour period
another 56 new deaths recorded that
takes the number of deaths within 28
days of a positive test for covet 19 to
153
916.
at least six people are believed to have
died in a crush at a stadium in the
capital of cameroon during the africa
cup of nations let's speak to our
african correspondent john sparks for
the latest um it was going to be a
sensational football tie that fans were
desperate to get inside what happened
john
good morning kate yeah this this
national celebration of football in
cameroon has turned into a bit of a
disaster certainly not the
the headlines that the organizers of the
africa cup of nations football
tournament were looking for at cameroon
the host nation playing comoros
last night in a key match at the africa
cup of nations playing in the capital
yayonde
in the the big stadium in the city and
it appears that supporters were trying
to gain
access after the match had started
through a single gate what i think
happened was that you had supporters
pushing from the back and those people
who were caught in the middle uh were
caught and they were they were crushed
in that and officials say that at least
as you were saying at least six people
were killed more than 40 people have
been injured and the emergency services
were clearly struggling to cope with
this at the government the tournament
organizers they say they're going to
launch an urgent investigation but i
think what we've got here is a
combination of inexperience this is the
first tournament of its kind that
cameroon has hosted you've got poor
policing and you've got the complexities
of covert at work here as well most of
the matches in this tournament have been
poorly attended people just haven't
turned up so the government's been
putting on free transport they've been
handing out free tickets as well but
then you've got stewards and police at
the stadia themselves asking for proof
of vaccinations and pcr tests that has
created big cues delays people trying to
get around the system as well and i
think ultimately that has resulted in
the chaotic scenes that we witnessed
last night
okay thank you thanks a lot
75 year old french adventurer who was
attempting to row across the atlantic
ocean
has been found dead in his overturned
boat at sea jean jacques sava had
previously made the crossing in a large
barrel in 2019 the former paratrooper
celebrated his 75th birthday at sea last
week with foie gras
and
champagne sadly he's now died
[Music]
two music's big names taylor swift and
damon alvin are involved in a spat over
who does and doesn't write their own
music
auburn accused swift of not writing her
own songs and she was furious she
responded on twitter i was such a big
fan of yours until i saw this your hot
take is completely false and so damaging
alban has since apologized
now here's something we won't all be
lucky enough to see on an evening walk
there you go a little bit of the aurora
borealis a finnish photographer
capturing this incredible scene of the
northern lights
appearing to reach into trees and
gardens earlier this month in lapland
the natural atmospheric phenomenon
happens when uh charged solar particles
collide with the earth's magnetic field
producing something like that how
stunning is that looks amazing doesn't
it
and yesterday we brought you pictures of
heavy snow in mykonos today we moved to
mainland greece the world famous
acropolis in athens blanketed in snow
polar jet stream is still affecting
parts of greece with schools closed in
the capital and power cuts still
affecting several regions quick look at
the weather for us
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
rather chilly and gray at the moment but
the cloud means most places are
frost-free northern scotland has some
patchy rain but it's dry just about
everywhere else
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
top stories for you this morning the
prime minister facing fresh calls to
resign after admitting to attending a
gathering for his birthday during
lockdown
thousands of u.s troops have been put on
standby and russian troops are being
moved into belarus as tensions grow
between east and west over ukraine
at least six football fans believed to
have died in a stampede outside a
stadium in cameroon during the africa
cup of nations
transport secretary said he refuses to
defend the prime minister and others who
took part in a gathering on his birthday
in downing street during the first
lockdown grant shouts told as mistakes
were made and said that the inquiry
launched by civil servant sue gray is
aware of the incident
it was his birthday and these are people
that he work with all the time as i said
i don't seek to
defend it this is for sue gray to
decide on
whether this was appropriate she'll make
the recommendations i think we can be
pretty clear the prime minister didn't
present a cake to himself this is
somebody coming in
with that cake and i've explained to you
that i'm furious with everybody but
you're not defending it are you but
because i'm purist with everybody who
broke the rules and a lot of different
people will have found that you know
perhaps unwittingly the transgress
transgressed the the the rules during
the period of lockdowns that is a fact
uh it's quite right that that's
investigated the prime minister
apologizes if uh and where
he has transgressed
uh joining us now is tamara at downing
street hi tamara um you heard there from
the transport secretary thoughts
well okay unwittingly transgressed the
rules what's really significant about
this latest party i think the 15th we've
now heard about that took place in the
building behind me is that downing
street are making no attempt to deny
that it happened or to say look wait for
sue gray we can't give you any details
there is no denial that the prime
minister went into the cabinet room was
presented with a cake by his wife and
apparently his interior decorator and
there were up to 30 people it's being
reported who were there who sang him
happy birthday now whether you think
that's a party or not and some have
raised questions about that it is not in
line with the guidance at the time which
was that you couldn't mix with other
people indoors for social events and
therefore it does share doubt on what
the prime minister told mps in
parliament which was that all the
guidance was followed in number 10. now
therein lies the problem we expect to
see grey's report still come back this
week because we're told that she already
knew about this one so it's not going to
delay her the publication of her report
what tory mps are looking out for is
did the prime minister mislead
parliament and if he did on this one by
saying that number 10 followed all the
guidance uh when they didn't that will
be a problem and they are weighing up uh
whether um he can survive this latest
scandal
okay tomorrow thank you
so what's happening as far as the
metropolitan police is concerned up
until now they um in the form of crested
dick have said that they will not be
investigating what happened at downing
street iva bennett is at new scotland
yard interestingly though um either
police who were on duty at the time and
downing street have been questioned by
sue gray
yeah they have and and supposedly
according to the news reports have
provided some damning evidence i'm not
actually at new scotland yards though i
am at the london fire brigade
headquarters and that is because
later on uh this morning here dame
crested addict the
commissioner for the metropolitan police
will be questioned here by the london uh
assembly's police and crime committee it
is a regular appearance she makes but
this time all focus will be on her
because we understand uh that on the
agenda will of course be partygate so we
understand she'll be facing questions on
that ironically actually actually the
chair of this committee used to be uh
sean bailey who himself had to resign
just before christmas after revelations
of his own
lockdown busting party came to light but
anyway today as i say will be the focus
will be on the metropolitan police
and dame crested a dick who is facing
growing calls to investigate these
claims of lockdown busting parties in
downing street despite all the apparent
evidence they continue to say scotland
yard continues to say that they will not
be they have no plans to investigate
reiterating only their statement last
night they've continued to put out that
if sugree's inquiry into partygate finds
evidence of a potential criminal offence
then they will
make further consideration they say on
whether or not
to investigate so all very non-committal
still
okay iva thank you
well as allies put nato forces on
standby amidst rising tensions between
russia and ukraine more ships and
fighter jets are being deployed to the
border but how far will nato go in
defense of ukraine
joining us now general is the richard
barrons bomber commander of the joint
forces command hello to you thank you
for joining us sir richard what should
britain be doing what should the uk be
doing at the moment
the uk should be combining with its
allies in nato and around the world in
making it absolutely clear to president
putin that the price he would pay for
invading ukraine
would be way way more than the russian
economy and society can sustain and on
that basis make him pull back
lord ricketts speaking last night saying
it's all talk we need some action
so the answer to this problem is not
primarily military from a uk or a nato
perspective ukraine isn't a member of
nato we need to make it clear to mr
putin that should he invade ukraine the
price he would pay in terms of sanctions
on his economy on banking on finance on
the access
uh russians including the russian
oligarchs have to our courts our banking
our insurance system all of that would
stop and and the price he would pay
therefore for invading uh ukraine would
be that his economy in society would be
in turn while he can't sustain
uh we're hearing uh that the united
states is uh has eight and a half
thousand troops on standby to
potentially um bolster um the border
between ukraine
and russia with another 45 000 troops
available if necessary is that something
that the uk should also be thinking
about either under the guise of nato or
otherwise
so the uk already has a battlegroup
permanently stationed in estonia and
plans will exist in the mod to to
reinforce it so uh nato as a whole is
reassuring those
uh member states that sit on the
periphery of russia and that's very
important to those member states and we
should also remember that one of the
things that mr putin is asking for and
it's completely unacceptable is that
nato should pull its own forces back
from its own members and by saying we're
going to reinforce mr putin might see
that actually this is really
counterproductive
brinkmanship in other words
yes i think the uk uh with the battle
group in estonia is doing the right
thing uh it would be useful to uh
illustrate how we can support that
battle group in estonia which sits on
the border with russia and has a long
history of confrontation there and we
should play our part this is a time when
nato as an alliance has to do what it
says on the tin and stand up for the
alliance as a whole
but house the withdrawal um disastrous
withdrawal from afghanistan signaled um
a shift away some might say from from
western military uh intervention and and
thus
um emboldened putin
so i think it it did i think it showed
that the the western stomach for
enduring a tough fight is is less but we
also need to be
very clear in distinguishing between
a campaign like afghanistan which was um
by any standards discretionary and a
long long way away from home and what
we're looking at now which is a direct
existential threat to our security our
values our interests and our prosperity
on the border of our principal alliance
nato this is wholly different and
therefore the response will be wholly
different uh what's your best guess
at the moment given so my best guess is
so uh
it's clear that russian forces are being
positioned so that they could
execute an invasion at short notice
they're not they're not there yet uh the
forces that are deployed give mr putin
options as to whether he tries to
launch a dash to encircle kiev from
belarus or whether perhaps more likely
he puts russian forces into the donbass
or or whether perhaps more
extraordinarily he invades ukraine and
tries to get uh as far as the desert all
of those options are militarily being
put in place however he must now be
thinking really hard about the price
russia would pay and the absolute key to
this is mr putin must think that if he
invades ukraine it strengthens his
regime we need to make it clear to him
that the effect an invasion would have
on the russian people and how they feel
about mr putin would be absolutely the
reverse and and he must see that
invading ukraine could lead to serious
questions about the longevity of his
regime and at that point i think he'd be
prudent to stop
so richard barron's good to talk to you
thank you for joining us on the
programme thank you
news has been on the front line with
ukrainian forces in our correspondent
stuart ramsey spoke to british men who
joined the ukrainian army
the guys know i'm not
you know a war tourist or a war junkie
and i'm with an organized unit i'm with
the government and i'm with a contracted
soldier so i've integrated so they know
i'm not just uh like i said uh just
sitting around and i'm gonna go home at
the end of it i've been here my family's
here my family is 15 kilometers i can
hear the shelling from my front room if
they come across the ball that we're
outgunned we haven't got air support
honestly a superior superiority we don't
have a naval fleet very strong naval
fleet
but ukrainians fight so we'll give them
a bloody nose that's for sure
well you can watch stewart's full report
on the sky news app on mobile or online
and coming up speaking to the chief exec
of heathrow airports new kovid 19 rules
mean travelers arriving in england will
no longer need a test of any sort really
from the 11th of february
[Music]
hello again you are watching the
breakfast program here on sky news uh
we've been talking about an event that
took place on the 19th of june 2020 in
the cabinet room of number 10 downing
straight and there was um 30 people in
the
there was birthday cake there was
singing of happy birthday mr prime
minister or whatever they called him uh
but um still
we are told they broke no rules dr salia
asham from families for justice a
frontline doctor who lost her father to
covid is with us now hello to doctor
thank you
for joining us tell us about your father
my father a son of huck chowdhury he's
he was 81
a retired teacher
sacrificed so much in his own life his
own ambitions um to help his children uh
to achieve theirs so he stood by me when
i
wanted to join the army um go to
sandhurst he was a very proud dad when
he came to my passing out parade um i
was inspired by him to go for that
um even though there weren't very many
people who looked like me at santos at
the time
he then helped us when we wanted to
decide on careers to become doctors
because i left the army to re-train as a
doctor and my siblings are medics as
well there's five of us who are doctors
so yeah huge sacrifice he used to
actually he told me later on in life he
used to go to peer prime minister's
questions and in parliament um
on wednesdays when he first arrived in
the country because he was very
politically engaged uh
i really believed in democracy and the
system and government um i feel that
through the pandemic he felt very let
down by the way it was being run
what would um what would you want to say
to the prime minister this morning
oh that i mean that's
such a huge question kay
you know
i would say
as someone who has trained in leadership
i trained at sound test our motto will
serve to leave
now he may well not be an army man but
he has taken up a position
of of leadership in office that is so
incredibly important and he's failed
this is all about leading by example
leadership is lonely leadership is not
fun
when you lead you have to put
those that you are responsible for above
the needs of your own it's not supposed
to be
a party it's not supposed to be
for your own benefit
it's a massive responsibility and he has
let us all down
leadership
respect in leadership is earned it's not
an expectation it's not an entitlement
i'm afraid he has no respect
i would say it's time
unfortunately to metaphorically fall on
your sword and to stand down
i also feel that it's not just about
moving to one side i feel that he's got
to brace himself
for what is going to come and that's a
full and thorough investigation of the
way that him and his government have led
us through the pandemic over 150 000
lives have been lost my dad is one of
those within that horrible statistic
and there needs to be accountability and
i want to see accountability i want to
see
those that have broken the rules led
poorly made wrong decisions
what did they gain from it all of these
answers need
to come
not just
you know for the basic reason for those
of us that have lost we need some
justice because only when we get that
and it's recognized that what we went
through was possibly just for some of us
avoidable
and the suffering of our loved ones
could have been avoided we need
accountability so that we can start to
heal with every single party revelation
it just brings us back to that time i've
spent the last 24 hours thinking about
my dad in that room and it was my
birthday
it was the second wave it was my
birthday
on the 22nd of december when my dad was
having his cpap mask put on
when his mouth started to bleed from the
pressure of it where he drank possibly
his last cup of tea
before he put the mask on and then was
too terrified to take it off uh
for the next five days because every
time he took it off
he was suffocating
so when i think about my future
birthdays and i've just had one i
remember that day there was no birthday
cake for us it just wasn't even a
question of having a birthday i cannot
even begin to think of the measure of
the man if he could contemplate that
um
he would i'm sure that your father would
have been so proud of you you said he
was um during his lifetime as he was
your siblings um as well just tell us a
little bit more about him before i let
you go he was he was 81 um he he had a
an enjoyable life i'm sure during those
81 years apart from towards the end you
must have very much looked up to him
oh very much so um you know i
i had
um an amazing career what i've done so
far i've i've i started life as a
journalist actually um because i've just
believed
in um
you know
putting truth to power to
finding out the truth um
and i got that all from my father part
of our daily traditions in our household
was sitting down after school and
watching the six o'clock news together
and then sometimes on rare occasions
being able to stay up for the 10 o'clock
if there was a big story and we did that
collectively as a family with my dad
sitting you know
nearest the television and it had to be
pin drop silence so we were watching the
news i caught that from my father and
everything else that followed came from
him it was his inspiration and his
support and his backing my dad was an
incredible chef and he had ambitions
to you know for his own career in that
in that world but he sacrificed that so
that he could provide for us
you know he worked as a teacher and then
he even did extra work as a security
guard on weekend to help pay for
attrition we owe him so much and i feel
that he's been so incredibly let down
and that's why i have to keep speaking
out about this not just for him but
everyone else who's lost mothers and
fathers and loved ones through this
awful pandemic and the awful way that
this government have managed it
doctor um i know it's always difficult
to relive what happened so thank you for
taking the time and for telling us about
your father thank you thank you thank
you
from the 11th of february rules are
going to be changed as far as
coronavirus testing for fully vaccinated
passengers arriving in england is
concerned let's talk about it with john
holland okay we heard from the transport
sector i don't know if you heard him on
the programme um earlier on john um he's
pleased and relieved i'm guessing you
are
yes and kay uh great to see you and this
is exactly what we were talking about a
couple of weeks ago getting back to
travel as he used to be without the need
for all these tests if you've been
doubly vaccinated so it's really
welcoming i think grant shaps has done a
fantastic job for the not just the
aviation sector but for anyone who needs
to travel for business visiting friends
and relatives now of course there are
some other things we will need we need
to get the tests lifted at the other end
of the journey because for most
countries you might need to go to you
will still need testing before you're
allowed into those countries so that's
something we'll work on and also a
playbook for what happens if there is
another variant of concern as is quite
likely to occur so that we don't have
this handbrake being slammed on by the
government and most people can travel
with confidence um even if there is a
new variant of concern
and what do you say to people who say
that the government and you are putting
people's um putting the economy ahead of
people's health
well actually not at all and
we're trying to balance health and
people's livelihoods people many jobs
across the uk millions of jobs depend
upon aviation in different forms
including those people who are
manufacturing goods that need to be
exported around the world many of them
travel on passenger planes out of
heathrow so it's important to get the
balance right and where we are in the
pandemic with the benefit of
vaccinations many people having been
jabbed three times now um it's the right
time to start opening up the economy and
learning to live with coving now of
course if there is another variant of
concern measures will be brought in we
hope those will be targeted just on
countries which have the variance of
concern rather than the blanket ban that
we saw a couple of months ago but this
is a really good step forward and we
should celebrate it and i think the
government has made the right step in
taking an international lead in
reopening international travel
what about those um passenger pesky
passenger locator farms
you need a degree as clever as yours in
order to get through them
i mean you'll be a lot smarter than i am
yes passenger locator forms are a hassle
for uh for anyone who is traveling they
always feel to be too complicated asking
the same question several times we're
told by the government that they are
simplifying those and
within the next month or so we should
see those becoming a little bit easier
to fill out and
really we need to get back to where
travel used to be where you don't have
to fill out all these forms or have
tests at both ends of the route now i
think in reality because kovit is going
to be with us for some time
then we're going to have to live with
these if not for coming into the uk then
certainly for going into other countries
and it's just going to be part of
international travel but if that's the
price we have to pay to be able to see
our loved ones or to go about doing our
business and i think it's a price worth
paying and at least we don't have the
very expensive tests that the government
had been requiring until quite recently
okay happy day uh for you finally uh
it's good to talk to you chief exec of
heathrow airport john holland k thank
you thanks kate
let the meet cake the prime minister
facing fresh calls to quit after downing
street admitted he attended a gathering
in the cabinet room to mark his birthday
in lockdown there was cake and there was
singing and his interior designer came
down three flights of stairs and went
next door into the cabinet room to see
him in the middle of a global pandemic
you do the math
[Music]